einigung auf europäische corona hilfen
die eu stellt ein paket im wert von 500
milliarden euro bereit
new yorks kampf gegen das virus auf
einer insel werden nun corona opfer in
massengräbern bestattet und karfreitag
diesmal ganz anders in einem autokino
feiern hunderte gläubige getrennt und
doch gemeinsam gottesdienst
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg ein karfreitag unter
besonderen umständen guten abend schön
dass sie dabei sind
wir beginnen mit einem positiven signal
aus brüssel angesichts der drastischen
folgen der korona krise haben sich die
finanzminister der eu doch noch
zusammengerauft es gibt jetzt ein
rettungspaket für jobs firmen und
angeschlagene staaten eine halbe billion
euro wird für kredite und garantien
bereit gestellt ob das reicht ist völlig
offen
stefan leifert berichtet in brüssels
europaviertel war gestern nach zum
ersten mal seit wochen wieder was los
ein stau sogar weil die polizei
kontrolliert wer warum trotz
ausgangssperre ins zentrum will
politisch aber bleibt das eu viertel
verweist mal wieder quälen sich die
finanzminister durch eine video schalte
16 stunden an zwei tagen das ergebnis
aber schließlich eine einigung
wir bauen jetzt europäische lösungen und
das in rekordzeit denn wir werden diese
herausforderung nur gemeinsam bestehen
dass corona paket der eu umfasst über
eine halbe billion euro 240 milliarden
für vorsorgliche kredite des
rettungsfonds esm europas
investitionsbank stellt 200 milliarden
für unternehmen bereit die eu-kommission
100 für kurzarbeitsprogramme und
schließlich wurde ein wiederaufbau vor
beschlossen dessen größe noch offen ist
ein zufriedener finanzminister meldet
sich noch in der nacht per video
heute ist ein großer tag europäische
solidarität noch stärker das ist wichtig
dass wir alle eine gemeinsame antwort
geben die unsere staaten in die lage
versetzt die gesundheitlichen
herausforderungen zu bewältigen aber
auch die wirtschaftlichen
herausforderung die damit verbunden sind
also erst die grenze die uns wichtig war
wird nicht überschritten
wir werden kein geld zur verfügung
stellen das nicht für die folgen der
wirtschaftskrise gedacht ist und die
eurobonds die wir ablehnen kommen nicht
die eu rauft sich per videochat zusammen
und zeigt solidarität in der krise ein
erfolg der laute streit ist zumindest
für kurze zeit erst einmal verstummt der
stefan leifert in brüssel ist das
verhältnis zwischen süd und nord ländern
denn jetzt wieder einigermaßen in
ordnung da diese tage des streits werden
schon ihre spuren hinterlassen denn
viele regierungen waren schwer befremdet
darüber mit welcher verbissenheit mit
welcher hartnäckigkeit regierungen und
jeweils andere seite hier in brüssel
ihre interessen vorgebracht hat aber
unter dem strich überwiegt das muss man
sagen doch die erleichterung denn dieses
hilfsprogramm wirkt ja auf zwei ebenen
es wirkt zum einen finanziell denn jetzt
ist zum ersten mal ein europäisches
auffangnetz da für den fall dass
nationale regierung mit ihren
hilfsmaßnahmen überfordert sind und auf
einer zweiten ebene wirkt es ja auch
politisch denn jetzt ist das signal da
das europa trotz anfänglicher chaostage
eben doch in der lage ist sich zu
gemeinsamen lösungen irgendwie
durchzuringen aber dennoch allen ist
klar dieser streit ist jetzt erstmal es
erst mal nur vertagt es gibt eine kleine
verschnaufpause aber viele streitthemen
stichwort eurobonds werden wiederkommen
wenn es dann um die frage geht wie das
große wiederaufbauprogramm nach der
korona krise zu finanzieren ist
dankeschön für diese einschätzung stefan
leifert aus brüssel
und jetzt der tägliche blick auf die
korona zahlen in deutschland aktuell
sind nach erhebungen der
johns-hopkins-universität hierzulande
100.000 1 119 1401 infizierte durch
tests bestätigt davon sind 52.000 407
bereits genesen
die zahl der todesfälle in verbindung
mit 19 beträgt 2600 7
ein wichtiger faktor ist der zeitraum in
dem sich die zahl der infizierten
verdoppelt dieser liegt inzwischen bei
16 7 tagen die ausbreitung verlangsamt
sich also weiter und heute also
karfreitag in corona zeiten das gedenken
an leiden und sterben jesu christi einer
der wichtigsten feiertage für christen
die dürfen aber nicht in die kirche
wegen des kontakt verbots blieben die
gotteshäuser leer durchaus umstritten
wenn man bedenkt
das in vielen bundesländern zum beispiel
baumärkte noch öffnen dürfen
die kirchen haben sich mit
live-übertragungen ihrer gottesdienste
beholfen und bemerkenswerte andere ideen
entwickelt dominic miller rosell
berichtet ein passion suite ein
parkplatz ein improvisierter alter sonst
gibt es auf dieser fläche autokino heute
vormittag feiern hier 900 düsseldorfer
christen einem ökumenischen gottesdienst
das ist die einzige chance dass wir
zusammenkommen wenn auch auf abstand die
kirchen sind leer es wird kräftig
gestreamt aber so haben wir die
möglichkeit ein gefühl von gemeinschaft
aufzubauen wenn auch ein etwas
eigenartiges
in der münchner matthäuskirche
gottesdienst ohne menschen die müssen an
diesem besonderen karfreitag zu hause
aus der ferne dabei seien menschen
fühlen sich heute auch gott verlassen so
wie jesus am kreuz menschen gehen durch
schwere zeiten haben angst so wie jesus
und das ist jetzt unsere geschichte
geworden und deswegen ist es gut dass
wir gemeinsam gottesdienst feiern
diesmal in einer leeren kirche aber
verbunden mit vielen menschen über
andere kanäle rutscht man ist 84 und hat
das glück dass kaplan franziskus von
boeselager sie einmal im monat besucht
zur krankenkommunion wie ist auch in
diesen tagen möglich und nun besonders
wertvoll
[Musik]
etwas hoffnung und zuversicht auch beim
gemeinsamen gedenken an das leiden und
sterben christi im autokino
einfach dieses getragen sein dieses
getragen in gemeinde und dieses
aufgefangen seien gerade jetzt in der
jetzigen zeit
es ist ein ungewöhnliches zusammenstehen
aber es ist eins am karfreitag 2020
auch in israel ist alles anders sonst
treffen sich zu ostern zehntausende
pilger aus aller welt im land um den
leidensweg christi nachzuempfinden
doch jetzt zu corona zeiten darf niemand
einreisen und es gelten ausgangssperren
die folge leere straßen leere kassen aus
israel nicola albrecht es herrscht
ausgangssperre im gesamten land und
ausnahmezustand in der heiligen stadt
alles ist dicht die via dolorosa der
biblische kreuzweg stillgelegt und leer
gefegt durch das virus 150 tausend
pilger und touristen sind im vergangenen
jahr zu ostern in die heilige stadt
gekommen
jetzt würden sich gerade tausende
gläubige durch die via dolorosa hier
drängen auf der traditionellen
karfreitagsprozession doch die ist in
diesem jahr dem corona virus zum opfer
gefallen
corona hat jerusalem fest im griff und
die virus bekämpfen ist hier sache der
polizei die atmosphäre ist bizarr außer
den einsatzkräften sind nur die menschen
die hier leben so wie es aussah sie
gehört der christlichen gemeinde in
jerusalem an ostern in der heiligen
stadt für sie erstmals beschränkt auf
ihre wohnung die pandemie zahlen fest im
blick schmückt sie die wie immer für
mich als christin ist die freude an der
auferstehung wichtig daran möchte ich
mich jetzt trotz corona erfreuen
wir dürfen nicht depressiv werden wie
viele gläubige vermisst auch so sahen
die karfreitags prozession doch nur der
katholische erzbischof und eine handvoll
mönche haben heute eine
ausnahmegenehmigung die laufen alleine
und mit abstand durch die via dolorosa
zur grabeskirche und erinnern an den
leidensweg jesu leeres jerusalem ostern
zu corona zeiten die dokumentation von
nicola albrecht sehen sie am
ostersonntag im anschluss an unsere 19
uhr heute nachrichten die mit abstand
meisten bestätigten corona fälle haben
längst die usa vor allem der bundesstaat
new york leidet dort weiß man
mittlerweile kaum mehr wohin mit den
leichen johannes hano
es sind bilder die verstören die man
nicht erwartet aus einem der reichsten
länder der welt in einfachen fichtenholz
kisten bringen strafgefangene die
leichen mit gabelstaplern in ein dafür
ausgehobenes massengrab reihe für reihe
immer drei särge übereinander hat island
ist eine kleine insel im long island
sound von new york city
seit jahrzehnten ein armenfriedhof hier
werden die begraben die keine familien
oder geld für eine würdevolle bestattung
haben meist obdachlose aber auch viele
säuglinge und totgeburten etwa 25
leichen werden die normalerweise pro
woche gemeinschaftsgräber beerdigt jetzt
während der korona krise sind es mehr
als 25 am tag und die gräber sind lange
grämen
die zahl der toten steigt unaufhörlich
die cluster die die leichenhalle der
krankenhäuser entlasten sollen kommen an
ihre kapazitätsgrenzen
bestattungsunternehmer und friedhöfe
wissen nicht mehr wohin mit all den
toten hunderte kurs 19 tote jeden tag
friedhöfe bestattungsunternehmen und
krematorien arbeiten fast rund um die
uhr hier in new york sind aber kaum noch
in der lage die vielen toten in würde zu
bestatten massengräber sollen da jetzt
entspannung bringen ist eine würdevolle
bestattung irgendwann wieder möglich ist
viele wochen könnte das noch dauern aber
es gibt hoffnung dass sich die lage
zumindest ein bisschen entspannen wird
immer weniger menschen werden in die
krankenhäuser eingeliefert das bedeutet
auch dass die zahl der toten
mittelfristig wohl sinken
der krieg in syrien vor corona hat die
welt dabei gebannt und ratlos zugesehen
gerade wegen der verzweifelten lage der
flüchtlinge dort doch jetzt ist es still
geworden
tatsächlich haben syrien russland und
die türkei ihre kampfhandlungen im
nordosten des landes deutlich reduziert
trotzdem ist die anspannung rund um die
stadt idlib groß einem virus haben die
menschen dort kaum etwas
entgegenzusetzen
ja preise zwar schweigen in idlib im
moment die waffen doch auch jetzt lauert
ein feind unsichtbar und niemand weiß
wie weit er bereits in die stadt
eingedrungen ist fieber messen und
desinfizieren am eingang des städtischen
krankenhauses notaufnahme zelte wurden
aufgebaut und doch fehlt es an allem was
wir am dringendsten brauchen sind ärzte
wir haben viel zu wenige außerdem sind
medikamente und medizinische geräte
mangelware
und wenn sich das virus irgendwann
verbreitet dann werden unsere vorräte
innerhalb weniger tage aufgebraucht sein
noch gibt es im großraum lebt keine
bestätigte corona infektion wohl auch
deshalb weil bis vor kurzem keine tests
gemacht werden konnten vor ein paar
tagen erst bekam das labor die nötigen
geräte
es ist ein wettlauf gegen die zeit denn
es ist wohl weniger die frage ob das
virus auch die flüchtlingslager erreicht
sondern eher wann rund 300.000 sitzen in
den zeltstädten entlang der grenze zur
türkei
dicht gedrängt dem virus fast schutzlos
ausgeliefert
unser camp ist genauso wenig auf das
corona virus vorbereitet wie alle
anderen keine desinfektionsmittel kein
medizinisches personal gott steh uns bei
wenn sich das hier ausbreitet das wäre
eine katastrophe
es würde viele opfer geben werden sich
die flüchtlinge dann über die grenze in
die türkei in bewegung setzen oder
werden sie bleiben wenn die waffen
weiter schweigen noch hält der
waffenstillstand eine corona epidemie
aber würde das überleben in idlib noch
schwerer machen als es sowieso schon
längst ist über alle neuen entwicklungen
im kampf gegen das virus halten wir sie
auch jederzeit online auf dem laufenden
und in der zdf- heute ab etwa in unserem
live blog zu
einer krise die weltwirtschaft liegt
lahm wegen der korona krise entsprechend
gering ist die nachfrage nach rohöl die
preise sind eingebrochen
jetzt wollen das öl kartell opec und
seine partnerländer die produktion
radikal drosseln künftig sollen pro tag
zehn millionen barrel öl weniger
gefördert werden
das entspricht rund zehn prozent der
weltweiten täglichen rubel produktion
nach deutschland steuererleichterungen
für mitarbeiter im home office fordert
die fdp
pauschal 100 euro im monat sollten als
werbungskosten angerechnet werden sagte
der stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der liberalen der
dpa
bisher können nur ein arbeitszimmer
steuerlich abgesetzt werden
viele hätten aber kein und jeder tag im
home-office weckt bei vielen wohl die
lust rauszugehen in die sonne etwas
neidisch blicken wir danach mecklenburg
vorpommern wo die einheimischen über
ostern nun doch an ihre strände dürfen
nach usedom zum beispiel die insel so
still wie sie über die ostertage wohl
noch keiner erlebt hat eigentlich geht
die saison hier jetzt richtig los heute
genossen vor allem die insulaner den
sand unter den füßen und mit dem nötigen
abstand den blick aufs meer wo in der
stille
noch deutlicher wurde wie schön es an
deutschlands küsten ist und es bleibt
schön auch morgen viel sonne im norden
sowie im bergland ein paar wolken in der
nordosthälfte elf bis 18 grad im
südwesten 18 bis 25 grad
auch der ostersonntag wird meist
freundlich nur mit wenigen schauern der
ostermontag deutlich kühler und
wechselhafter claus kleber spät um
viertel vor elf im heute-journal für sie
bereit wir sind morgen wieder da wenn
sie mögen und wünschen ihnen auf jeden
fall und trotz allem schöne feiertage
auf wiedersehen